you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is a game
from season 10 of the top chess engine
championship 2017 24 of the world's very
best chess engines doing battle in this
event over the next three to four months
the game we're gonna have a look at is
between comodo playing on the white end
weighing in at a beefy 3230 and wasp
rated 2824 just to put things into
perspective the current world number one
Magnus Carlsen his current rating is 28
37 so what more to have this is a game
from stage 1 round 2 played on October
15th and time controls 60 minutes each
with a 10 second increment let's dive in
here see what happened Komodo kicking
off with e4 wasp replying with e5 and
the Vienna game on board so this was
nice to see don't get to see this
opening so often at the top level how
will the top engines handle it Bishop c5
Knight f3 d6
the things I enjoyed about this game was
how quickly the opening result produced
an imbalance white goes hunting for the
bishop pair and gets just that five
moves in and we have a nice struggle
ahead of us white with the bishop pair
black with some space
nice grip currently over d4 moreover we
might also want to look at the central
structure currently tipping in White's
favor two to one
continuing next few moves nothing
exciting a five grabbing some Queen side
space there will be no peace on g4
there's now a spot for the King later on
a for more space more options for the
rook will white do anything about this
guy no white ignores it and castles on
move nine
his game for me was instructive in many
ways in all phases and in this opening
slash middle game position this was the
first point in the game I found
instructive
I'd like to elaborate some on it instead
of the move castles one of the moves
that I would be thinking of and I
wouldn't be surprised if many other
players would be considering this move
a3 is a common move you would see in
reply to a form which is stopping the
the pawn from going any further and not
you know by playing a3 you don't allow
this pawn to make your beep on flinch an
issue with playing a3 is that you can't
really successfully now go forward with
a central expansion one of the ideas
that we're going to observe from this
game is that white goes for c3 and
deform however if you have a three in
there let's just put two moves on if you
have first a3 in and now look for c3
what have you just done
you've created a hole on b3 it already
has some support and is not long off
from being occupied now by either a
knight or Bishop both would be a great
inconvenience to the white queen side
the air form the a pawn rests on his
home square stays put
castles castles see three white is
prepared to meet a3 with b3 there's one
downside that will later on observe
there's one downside white will observe
and that is a Bishop e6 move Bishop
applying pressure to a2 makes life
difficult for the Queen rook it's a bit
of an inconvenience for the rook to have
to babysit the a2 pond but white is not
budging with that pawn does not want to
weaken b3 Queen e7 Bishop d2 38 Queen c2
blacks eyeing up f4 rook on F 2 d1 he
has a responsibility now right away not
right now but soon h6 there should be
three the knight jumps in and chop chop
we no longer have the bishop pair
advantage but something that we now
transition to something else it's a
structural shift black has space still
space on the Queen side with this guy
and some King side space with this guy
here white on the other hand has a
central majority that has now been
converted into two to zero so do you
play d4 right now and set these guys
into motion
no rook to d2 this was a second
instructive moment for me and why not D
for D for straightaway you could do but
you allow the knight to jump into B for
how great of an inconvenience would this
really be I don't I can't say for
certain but I just want to go as far as
this point here notice that there is
this idea black has which is taking
advantage of the fact that the bishop on
e 2 is unprotected
light doesn't have to rush in this
position that's this is another this is
a another way to look at this position
black can not prevent deform so let's do
just a little bit more building up
before playing d4 rook to D to his
securing the bishop on e2 so in the
event of this push and the night before
move the Queen can drop back without
fear of an ensuing Bishop f5 let's say
Bishop is not a tactical liability only
after 95 do we have d4 Knight takes
bishop takes
Bishop to e6
pressure on 82 don't be too quick to try
and slam the door on the bishop with d5
here because you'd be giving up
ee 5 it's important to realize now that
we're working with light square bishop
spots
having a light square bishop we want to
coordinate our structure with our
bishops so ideally light is looking
forward to placing upon on e5 pawns on
dark bishop on light
King 2h to another tidying up type of
move prophylactic type move what is this
why is this move may be played well in
some lines a queen g5 move may come
about and pin the pond to the king and
as a result Bishop takes pawn would be a
threat that's no longer the case with
the King on h2
g6 black is looking for small
improvements here King ideally would
like to be on a dark square opposite the
bishop here a little reposition for the
White Queen
f 6 so there's a new piece of criteria
to look into now after this f 6 advance
king safety is what springs to mind for
me how's the how how are the shelters
for each King have 6 g 6 H 6 versus this
structure here for white the White King
is far more secure much more difficult
to get at the White King than the black
King the seventh rank now that there
isn't a pawn here is weakened
so black needs to be very careful all
major pieces are still present let's see
how things move forward a 5
pawn takes rook takes one rook is off c6
so this structure negates the bishop and
well what's this recurring to do it's
kind of unclear white still doesn't want
to play this a3 move and give up this be
three square and well okay this pawn on
f4 he's unprotected why puts pressure on
it
and one might think I'll you just defend
it with g5 but black does something
different f5 so this was another moment
in the game I was kind of scratching my
head with why
why f5 why not let's say g5 on g5 we
could have a capture Queen B for this
position is opening up and where is this
king's home forget about this structure
this isn't an adequate structure to
defend the black king and this Queen is
super active notice also that this file
has opened up and this rook will have a
purpose
doesn't get more active than the Queen
on b4 really pressure on both of these
black pawns and tying down a rook etc so
black please f5 here doesn't want to see
any pawn captures or pawn for pawn
captures and it seems like white could
just go ahead at this point and pick up
the pawn but doesn't
instead playing d5 again a question is
what is this route going to do is he
gonna find activity here no neither is
the bishop what about the D file no e
file no how does white try to crack open
this position well light does so by
playing first d5 changing the structure
a reason to not take here is because of
Queen B form in this queen is super
active from b4 just I was pointing out a
white queen um before the black Queen on
b4 is excellent a lot of pressure is
placed on the white pawns and there may
soon be additional pressure against
deform a reason for d5 is not only to
change the structure we now have an open
C file but also to allow the Queen to
take f4 and prevent now the Queen B for
move we also have both sides with a
passed pawn so let's see how play
develops Queen c5 rook c1 Queen b6 black
cannot allow this rook to get to the
seventh h4 at some point maybe h5 to
break down the structure Queen takes
pawn that's basically leading to me so
d4 Bishop to e2 both bishops this is an
interesting moment both bishops the
least valuable piece is allocated to
defending the past pawns
so courtesy eight rooks are off Bishop
c4 looking for a push and then there's
all sorts of ideas Queen to e5 maybe
Queen to b8 opening up this diagonal
Queen c5 Bishop d3 and h5 so one of the
ideas white might have here is to play
g4 for example Bishop e6 g4 can follow
and capturing isn't any good because the
Queen slips into f6 so h5 is designed at
preventing g4 but there's a great
drawback connected with that move it
weakens the dark square g5 so something
white eyes up straight away Queen g3 and
it's paving the way for f4 we see that
king of seven f4
now this pawn his strength has increased
he is now a connected passed pawn
Bishop e6 Queen to g5 and Queen to e7
it's right about this point
we're Komodo realized that it's
basically winning and not until several
moves later maybe about a dozen moves
later did wasp realize oh yeah um I'm
cooked I'm dead so let's see this
interesting endgame now that the queens
are off material is balanced let's get
one more move in there a three material
is balanced but when we considered the
value of these two passed pawns this one
wins out he's connected in past he has
the support of a pawn
moreover compare the bishops we have a
case now of good versus bad Bishop Kings
get towards the center and what more to
add King to e1 if Bishop takes pawn that
drops b5 now this guy is defended and
white doesn't do anything with this pawn
plays c6 allows the g2 pawn to be
captured this was very interesting eise
Evan
Bishop c6 King to d3 King to c5 and
Bishop to D our first Bishop to f3 he
can't take the bishop just Queens Bishop
goes to e8 and Bishop to d1 so white is
down upon or actually do you think that
white is down upon in this position I I
see this position in a different way I
don't see that the material is I don't
see that black is really up material why
do I think this it's because these two
pawns are restricting these three so
they can't really successfully advance
you could advance the black can advance
these pawns and create a passed pawn but
it comes with a cost
and that cost is you'd have to first
give white a passed fun
continuing King to d6 allows king takes
d4 straight away so this voluntary
retreat of the king
well black goes back voluntarily if if
black doesn't do that with let's say
Bishop to have seven eventually white
will force the King back with the move
b4 and notice the dark squares are
controlled nicely by the pawns if the
King slips over we insert a check and
then again as mentioned by force we take
that d4 pawn out and after b4 if
captures Bishop takes pawn and Bishop to
g8 the King has to move the bishop can't
move if the bishop moves there's Bishop
f7 and promote King to d6 and we win the
pawn like that in short again the King
went back voluntarily if he didn't do
that he would be forced to d6 King d6
King takes pawn King takes pawn King to
e5 what's the big advantage that White
has in this position King position not
Material it's not a material advantage
that we have here it's a king position
advantage it's a better bishop advantage
King f6 King to d6 notice
of the white king is preventing the
black King from doing anything
constructive meanwhile like and take
some time out to pinpoint b5 and that's
what we have next king c5 King to e7 and
this is really the last instructional
moment of the game came to e7 is the
game move but after King to e6 you could
very easily if you're if it's a human
that's playing on the white side here
you could very easily throw away your
advantage by capturing on b5
capturing on b5 would result in a draw
and it's it's white who could very
easily lose this position King d5 if you
take the pawn g5 chop and you cannot
stop this pawn
the draw here would be to play king to
be form the main point however is that
if King te6 was played you don't take
this pawn but instead go to eh and force
the King to f6 and only then do you snip
the pun now the king is out of position
and he will not be able to establish
himself on d5 so easily so in the game
it was king to e7 Bishop takes pawn
Bishop takes Bishop King takes g5 is
tried pawn on F we don't want to allow
this guy to become passed so F takes G
f4 the king is in time to hunt him down
and this is simply a one King and pawn
endgame wiping up a pawn now and this is
as far as the game goes it's terminated
at this point due to the the tournament
rules white is winning and black knows
it as well both both engines clearly
know that this is a win for white if it
was to continue king d4 I'm not even
sure what to consider or suggest here
you could already push pawn takes here
and this King is just way too slow
something like this and yeah he's just a
mile away from
stopping the pond and yeah we don't have
to go any further so interesting game I
like how it progressed again as
mentioned at the very early stage having
the bishop pair for white and a
two-to-one majority in the center that
was eventually converted
- what exactly Bishop for Knight
exchange here we're now working with a
two to zero majority in the center this
was eventually converted into a bit of a
space advantage in the center with the
pawn on e5 and well also this f6 move
King position then became a big factor
and towards the very end here as we saw
we had a good versus bad Bishop position
and yeah that was telling in this
endgame instructive moment to be able to
give up the pawn on g2 and know that
well really these two pawns kill these
three so we're we're good there and very
nice technical phase for sure in this
game so anyhow feel free as usual to
leave any feedback to this video in the
comment section below
hope you're having a great day and I'll
catch you in the next video that's all
for now take care bye
you